[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is a sky news
special programme on the war in ukraine
our top story at a turning point the
verdict of the ukrainian president as
russian forces edge closer to kiev
[Applause]
digging in ukrainian troops try to hold
their lines on the outskirts of the
capital
as kiev prepares some major cities
including denipro come under attack for
the first time as russia broadens its
assault
today they're digging and digging
filling sandbag after sandbag to try to
protect these features
we report from the southern city of
odessa where residents are preparing for
a russian assault
the u.n security council debates
disputed russian claims that ukraine is
developing chemical weapons but the u.s
president has a warning of his own for
vladimir putin i'm not going to speak
about the intelligence but but russia
would pay a severe price chemical
mr putin meets his closest ally as the
parent company of facebook and instagram
becomes the latest victim of the russian
clampdown on foreign media
and we report from poland as the un says
more than two and a half million
refugees have now fled the fighting in
ukraine
[Music]
a very good evening thanks for joining
us i'm jonathan samuels and this is a
special program on the war in ukraine
the country's president vladimir
zelensky said today that the conflict
has now reached a strategic turning
point as more major cities across the
country become caught up in the russia
offensive the main focus however remains
the capital kiev with russian forces
moving three miles closer in the past 24
hours according to a senior u.s defense
official well let's take a look now the
latest developments there's been renewed
fighting on the outskirts of the capital
and in the eastern city of kharkiv where
a psychiatric hospital was hit by a
russian airstrike there's no word on
casualties but 330 people were at the
hospital
the knee pro is the next likely target
as russia's southern offensive moves
north
two other strikes near airports in the
western cities of lutsk and ivano
frankevsk were also reported
skies katarina ratocci has the latest on
today's developments
russia hadn't prepared for this
with guns
and anti-tank missiles
ukrainian forces repel an assault
outside of the capital kiev
this fire fight was filmed yesterday
[Applause]
this soldier says
according to british intelligence
unexpected ukrainian ground resistance
is limiting the progress of russia's
forces
the foreign fighters amongst them seen
by russia as western provocation
regarding the gathering mercenaries from
around the world for ukraine we see them
the western sponsors of the ukrainian
regime do not keep it secret they do it
openly disregarding international law
but how long can this resistance hold
out
ukraine's president today made a
heartfelt appeal to the war weary
i know many people are feeling tired now
i understand it i understand it's all
about emotions and it's life when we
mobilize our efforts and when we can see
that we can win
we expect the enemy to fall quicker but
the truth is in this war the fight we
need more time we need more patience we
need to be wise we need to do our job
the best we can to gain the victory
but uk intelligence says russia is
planning a fresh wave of assaults
this video was released by the russian
army
they purport it shows their troops on
the move on the outskirts of kiev
u.s defense officials say some russian
contingents are now just nine miles away
other major cities are also under attack
captured on cctv this morning
sky news has verified this video from
just before 6 a.m
there's no obvious military target here
this was a shoe factory
now it's embers and ash
as air raid sirens blare
civilians here scramble for safety
underground
more than two million people have now
fled ukraine
those still here in besieged cities like
the northern kharkiv find shelter
wherever they can
in the southern port city of mariopol
there is yet another attempt at
establishing a humanitarian corridor to
help hundreds of thousands of people
safely escape a place where there's no
food and no fuel
the russian army continues to do
airstrikes airborne
artillery shelling
and
their
troops are behind the city and in some
districts of the city we have war uh
street battles so as you understand the
humanitarian situation decrease our by
our second by second
ukrainian officials today appealed yet
again for international military mike to
maintain a no-fly zone
the u.s president though clear and firm
they wouldn't support one
we'll defend every single inch of nato
territory
of the full might of the united and
galvanized nato
we will not fight a war against russia
in ukraine
direct confrontation between nato
and russia is world war iii something we
must strive to prevent
but as families cower in basements
there's the specter of further
atrocities
russia says the us has been making
biological weapons in ukrainian labs
claims the us and uk say are a fake
story to cloak a possible chemical
attack of russia's own
a fake story with very real victims
living in places where aid can't get in
and from where they can't get out
catherine of autopsy sky news
well our security and defense editor
deborah haynes is in lev in western
ukraine for us this evening uh deborah
what more can you tell us then about
these reports of fresh wave of attacks
by russia russia really ramping up the
pressure
yes well i went to visit the site of one
of the attacks in the west we've had
over the last more than two weeks now of
this war the focus of the russian um
attack or offensive has been in the
south in the east and in the north
obviously encircling kiev the capital um
but overnight last night well in the
early hours of this morning actually
about sort of quarter to six this
morning there was air strikes against
two military airfields in the west of
the country so an expansion really of
the targeting
the belief is that it's a sign that
russia is trying to take out the
ukrainian ability to use its air force
against russian targets which has been
something that russia has failed to do
since the start of the invasion but also
some are interpreting this as a signal
that the that nowhere in this country is
safe the west has been more of a safe
haven and here in la viv it's been a
real transit hub for those you know more
than a million and a half refugees many
of them coming through this point to get
into next door poland and so an
expansion there and then also in terms
of the um the actual war itself uh
and who's involved in it there are real
concerns from the ukrainian side tonight
that belarus might be about to get
involved um you've had reports over the
last few days of um concern over the
posturing of bella russian soldiers
paratroopers on the border with ukraine
belarus a close ally one of the closest
allies that russia has in the region and
um tonight a warning that they might be
launching some offensive roundabout now
that the time that was given by the
ukrainians was nine o'clock local time
which is now um they said they accused
russia of launching airs or launching
attacks from ukrainian airspace using
russian jets against belarussian
villages on the border and saying that
that could be some kind of provocation
we've yet to see if that would happen um
belarus but the better russian president
has denied that his country would get
involved but his country frankly has is
already involved in terms of allowing
its soil to be used for russian troops
to launch their invasion and also to
launch missiles against ukraine so it's
already been sanctioned because of that
but that potentially if that were to
happen that would be a serious deepening
and widening of this conflict bringing
in a whole other country albeit one very
much under the uh influence of russia
into the conflict too
okay deborah in lev thank you and the
latest developments in the russian
offensive we'll feature in saturday's
papers we'll have our extended press
preview and news review from half past
10 this evening with tonight's news and
tomorrow's headlines joining us will be
daily mirror economist susie boniface
and assistant comment editor at the
daily telegraph
madeleine grant
well taking over the city of odessa in
the south of ukraine is seen as one of
russia's next strategic goals civilians
are joining in with the efforts to
defend the city against an amphibious
attack that could be imminent sky's nick
martin is in odessa from where he sent
this report
[Applause]
on the beaches of odessa they're
preparing to defend themselves
they know the russians aren't far away
now
[Applause]
[Music]
and who could have predicted this a
choir provides a wartime serenade to
volunteers
[Music]
everyone here just wants to survive
odessa is a major port on the black sea
strategically important to vladimir
putin his invasion though has brought
life to a standstill here
and precious monuments are now shrouded
in sandbags
just a little over three weeks ago it
was bustling here
you know odessa is famous for its cafes
and its restaurants and its sort of
boutique shops
but now it's absolutely deserted and the
one thing that strikes you on every
street corner
are the barricades
and behind me is the famous opera house
here in odessa the last time
it was protected like this was the
second world war
history really is repeating itself
on the street we meet an elderly couple
and i want to know what they think about
russia's chances here
there's a no-go russian
army
no
they'll not get through only
back
in russia
daniel was born in odessa his wife and
children have now fled and he's staying
to fight
i think you can hold back this russian
offensive sure
we already shown since 24th that we are
holding back and we we kicked some ass
sorry
but we kicked some ass
[Applause]
in odessa's trendy food hall they've
turned it into an aid station
inga a lawyer is organizing the effort
what's your message to vladimir putin
only what message stop the war it's our
country go
go away just doing anything with your
russia
everything you want but never come gain
ukraine we hate you and all the politics
we don't need your support
and then a reminder of the dangers here
one more scholarship with alaska so
while we were in here about to do an
interview the air raid sirens have gone
off so everyone's been asked to
go down into the shelter so they're
leaving this area now
a guy grabs a guitar and begins to play
[Music]
no one here knows what's going to happen
next
nick martin sky news odessa
[Music]
well the united nations security council
has held another emergency session today
with russia making unsubstantiated
claims that ukraine is developing
chemical weapons earlier the russian
delegate was speaking and brandished
some images relating to the airstrike on
the maternity hospital in mariopol paul
the fight is a radical
converted to that building
to a and an attack base this is
something that we warned about even that
apparently you don't listen or you don't
hear what it is photography yeah did you
see the photos
the allegedly destroyed maternity
hospital the building
was destroyed by a bomb you what you can
see
is a building without windows but it's
not destroyed here are the photos
what would have happened to a building
if it underwent a bomb or a
strike or shelling as well as to those
who were inside the building what would
have happened to us
so we have the videos from inside the
building here they are the ones
that there is a disorder or returned
furniture and untouched
intact chairs once again can you imagine
what kind of destruction would have
remained in the wake of a building hit
by a rocket or a bomb
well at the meeting both the u.s
representative linda thomas greenfield
and uk representative dame barbara
woodward reiterated their belief that
russia was using these unsubstantiated
claims as an excuse to launch a chemical
weapons attack in ukraine
i will say this once
ukraine does not have a biological
weapons program
there are no ukrainian biological
weapons laboratories supported by the
united states we have serious concerns
that russia may be planning to use
chemical or biological agents against
the ukrainian people
the attempt intent behind these lies
seemed clear
and it is deeply troubling
russia has today
brought into the security council
a series of wild
completely baseless
and irresponsible conspiracy theories
let me put it diplomatically
they are utter nonsense
our u.s correspondent greg milam is in
washington for us greg another un
meeting many will say lots of talking
lots of discussion but actually is there
any action
well this was a meeting called by russia
and in many respects it's what the uk
and the u.s has been warning russia
would do for a number of days the prime
minister yesterday of course speaking to
sky news about this the suggestion that
russia would allege that the u.s and
ukraine were developing
biological weapons
dismissing as you heard they're
dismissing that as as the truth but
saying russia would use that as a as a
pretext uh to carry out a chemical
weapons attack of its of its own and and
the the un the u.s ambassador
they're saying that even holding this
meeting was in many ways a false flag a
pretext that russia was trying to create
to justify whatever they might do and
saying that it's russia that has the
well-documented history of using
chemical weapons supporting president
assad in syria and his use of chemical
weapons they have a biological program
the us says that violates
international law and these allegations
from russia have been around for a long
time but they really ramped up in the
days before
the invasion to create that that pretext
the question is what will the west uh do
about it joe biden was speaking earlier
today unveiling some new sanctions he
said if chemical weapons will use there
will be a severe price
for russia but we don't know what that
is and remember he was vice president
when barack obama talked about red lines
over chemical weapons in syria and they
didn't take the action that people
expected
greg in washington thank you
well despite the continuing escalation
in the conflict vladimir putin said
today that there are certain positive
developments in talks between russia and
ukraine that assessment came as he met
his ally bella russian president
alexander lukashenko in moscow but in
the latest clampdown on access to
foreign media within russia the social
media giant meta the parent group of
facebook was labeled an extremist
organization after the company said it
would temporarily allow people to post
calls calling for vladimir putin's death
our moscow correspondent diana magnay
has more
russia's minister of defense sergey
shoigu distributing medals for bravery
pictures released for domestic
consumption to rally the people behind
what russia refuses to call anything
other than a special military operation
these soldiers made it back from the
front others have not
but it's a criminal offence in russia to
report anything other than the official
number which was 498 on march the 2nd
and has not been updated since
according to mr shoigu the operation is
going to plan
in a meeting of the security council he
told russia's president that there were
16 000 requests from so-called
volunteers in the middle east who wanted
to help liberate in his words the people
of donbass
a claim quickly backed up by this video
from russia's ministry of defence are
fighters chanting their support for the
syrian president and for russia
yesterday
vladimir putin went on to meet his
belarusian counterpart alexander
lukashenko a frequent visitor to the
kremlin these days who declared that
russia had acted not a moment too soon
as both leaders reassured the other that
they'd weather the sanctions storm the
u.s imposed additional measures removing
russia's most favored nation trading
status banning further imports and the
export of luxury goods to russia
luxury here has already shut down the
symbols of what it meant to get rich in
the 90s and the early years of putin's
reign all pulling out
instagram was banned today the symbols
of connectivity in modern russia
shutting down one by one
in soviet times people tended to talk
about the system only in the safety of
their own kitchens it was too dangerous
to disagree publicly and it feels a bit
as though russia is returning to that
state with the kremlin today with this
message to anyone who might disagree
with what they are doing a true russian
is never ashamed of being russian if
anyone says so this person is not
russian this person is not with us
many thousands of russians have left the
country over the last two weeks
sanctions will rip away the futures that
the rest expected they'd have even if
many may not really know it yet
dana magney sky news moscow
this is a sky news special program on
the war in ukraine coming up after the
break we'll take a look at new plans to
help british people open up their homes
to ukrainian refugees
welcome back the uk government is set to
announce proposals to allow british
people to open their homes to ukrainians
fleeing the russian invasion the new
scheme expected to be confirmed next
week will create a new sponsored
humanitarian route for those ukrainians
without family links here in the uk it
comes after boris johnson came under
increasing pressure across the political
spectrum for failing to do enough to
help refugees from the conflict skies
becky johnson reports
we hope and pray that god gives you the
strength and courage to face these awful
times
she's collected hundreds of messages and
raised thousands of pounds to send to
ukraine but lisa kay wants to do more
this room is all ready for two children
a british family who fled from kiev will
arrive at her home in warwickshire this
weekend
she wants to give her other spare rooms
to ukrainians
i'd like to be able to look after them i
think they've been through absolute hell
and for me
it makes me feel
guilty
that i can just sit here and have all
this space
and then there's those people that have
had to leave like their dads and
brothers and
uncles and grandfathers behind it
just really really gets to me
the government says it'll set out more
detail in the coming days about how
british people will be able to offer up
their homes to ukrainian refugees but it
follows heavy criticism of the home
office for the delays and red tape being
faced by people trying to get into this
country
at this refugee support centre they have
many questions we don't know the
logistics of this scheme yet
and we don't know the eligibility
criteria how long they will be able to
stay in the uk hopefully access to
employment study and benefits
and even better refugee status support
to find employment register with gps
school places for their children this is
my granddad
grandma
my aunt
the details will matter to families like
julius their hometown now in russian
control they escape to poland and are
waiting to see if the uk will allow them
in she has this plea please make it
faster
because it's very time consuming for
elderly people and people with children
like in my case let them come and then
i'm sure that all of the documentation
can be handed in in the uk already where
they save
the british public have already shown
their willingness to help will that
extend to opening their homes to those
most in need becky johnson sky news in
the west midlands
and our deputy political editor sam
coats is with me here in the studio and
sam we're expecting a big announcement
from the government on monday aren't we
about to the whole refugee situation
that's right michael gove the leveling
up secretary is in the lead he's going
to announce this resettlement package
people being able to open their homes to
people coming from ukraine do their part
in this big effort and underpinning it
essentially is going to be a second
route for people to come in from ukraine
at the moment you can come in uh
effectively if you have a
permanent visa and you come from ukraine
you can bring in your extended family so
there's a family route from monday there
is going to be a sponsorship route so
what that means is that if a local
authority or an individual
agrees that they're going to house you
look after you
then you will be allowed to enter the
details of how this will work will be
complicated and that's what michael gove
has been setting out now the
government's come under fire in recent
days because some of this stuff uh
there's been criticism from the
opposition parties that it wasn't fast
enough quite a lot of fire aimed
actually at the home secretary pretty
patel who has been cast in some quarters
as not being generous enough to uh
refugees what's interesting we've been
speaking to people across government
today at sky and
what's interesting is that actually
pretty patella in some cases has been
pushing for schemes that we're going to
be a bit more open to more people coming
from ukraine but the block actually came
in some cases in number 10
the number 10 policy unit and others
just going hang on a moment we want to
make sure everybody's properly checked
we've got to be careful about exactly
what we're opening the doors to uh so
perhaps not quite the politics that some
uh some were expecting in that but we
will get details on what number 10 think
are a very generous uh new scheme when
michael gove uh stands up in the house
of commons on monday okay we'll find out
more then uh sam thank you for the
moment you're watching sky news special
programme on the war in ukraine coming
up after ukrainian forces show off
captured russian vehicles i'll be
talking to a former u.s ambassador to
ukraine about the latest developments in
the conference
[Music]
this is a sky news special program on
the war in ukraine our top stories this
evening a senior u.s defense source says
russian forces have advanced three miles
closer to kiev in the last 24 hours
at the united nations america has
dismissed claims by russia that it's
helping ukraine make chemical and
biological weapons
and the un says more than two and a half
million people have now fled ukraine the
uk government is planning a new scheme
to help british people take in refugees
uh well i can speak now to john herbst
former u.s ambassador to ukraine and now
director of the eurasia center at the
atlantic council good to see you this
evening thank you very much for your
time and perhaps we can just start with
your thoughts uh 16 days in
to this conflict what is russia's
position tonight there's talk of a fresh
wave of attacks coming and also
belarus getting involved
okay look
the russian offensive in ukraine has
gone much worse than anticipated
they have
largely been bogged down around mariupol
around harkev
um around keefe
it is true though that over the past i
don't know 24 36
72 hours we've seen some real movement
in the south
and some movement around around keith
uh
but
they've only taken at this point you
know almost two and a half weeks into
their major invasion
one significant ukrainian city her
in the south
uh
even though they've actually been
surrounding mariupol since almost before
this new invasion began they still
haven't taken the city
what this means is they're starting to
use the barbaric tactics they used in
chechnya and in northern syria which is
massive bombardment of civilian areas
you i'd say not so much without regard
for civilian lives but to kill civilians
as well as to kill soldiers and that way
to
bomb
their opponents
into submission this of course is a war
crime as is their use of thermobaric or
vacuum bombs and their use of cluster
bombs
when you hear president zielinski say as
he has done in the last 24 hours that
ukraine has reached a strategic turning
point he's convinced that ukraine can
win but that surely is wishful thinking
certainly if if nato
doesn't do anymore
well actually no
i think that in fact ukraine is likely
to win this conflict
but the question is how many more tens
of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians must die
before that becomes clear to the rulers
in the kremlin
right now you have a war
of one man vladimir putin on a whole
people ukrainian people
it's pretty clear from watching that
bizarre video when putin announced his
intention to to move
and then watching his bizarre video when
he announced raising nuclear alert that
even his most senior advisers are
uncomfortable with this
and by launching this major invasion
putin has greatly weakened russia
economically and geopolitically
um he has united europe and
and nato in ways he did not anticipate
even germany now understands that putin
is a threat to world peace
and he has brought on his head and on
russia's head sanctions which will crush
the russian economy and in the middle
term and in the long term even the
russian military because without it
without a real resources it's hard to
keep your military in shape
the only real question now is again how
much pain is he going to inflict on
ukraine before his war there is
understood to be a failure he can reduce
ukrainian cities to rubble
he can take more parts of the country he
will never however control more than the
cities and the roads he have he'll haste
if he actually uh significantly reduces
the ukrainian military he hasn't done
that yet which is also an important
achievement he will face a partisan war
which will take russian lives russian
soldiers lives add infinitum and at some
point the russian people will realize
this is a loser of a war and even the
russian elite intimidated by their
increasingly authoritarian leader will
understand that putin's policies are a
disaster for russia
so so in the long term this is this is
the demise of president putin that seems
to to be what you're saying but in in
the short term the ukrainians are going
to be pummeled aren't they in in coming
days and weeks you wrote i think
i'm right in saying that you were part
of a a letter to president biden asking
for more to be done what did you mean by
that what what exactly were you asking
for
look the biden team deserves credit for
accurately seeing the russian threat
and laying out i would say a solid
framework for addressing it and and
mitigating it
but in actual
implementation they've been slow and
timid
i would say that's especially true on
the military side
uh you know they talked back in the
spring a year ago when you had the first
russian buildup about providing
additional arms to ukraine they didn't
do it in the spring after the russian
drawdown
they only began to do it in connection
with this crisis in late january
we should have been sending additional
arms to ukraine
back in certainly november or december
well before this new russian invasion
began
and even after the decision
to send additional arms to ukraine
we we waited until the end of january to
send our first stinger missile to
ukraine that's a disgrace
and now you had the disgraceful decision
by the administration
not to expedite the sending of migs from
our nato allies
into ukraine and they did it frankly
because they were afraid of quote
unquote the escalatory effect
as moscow was bombing the hell out of
ukrainian civilians they're talking
about sending
warplanes to ukraine as quote-unquote
and escalation
that is timidity parading as prudence
isn't the problem that you know who who
decides uh what what an escalation is we
don't know what putin's thinking
and his behavior has been so erratic uh
uh and so delusional in many ways you
know he may well see that as an
escalation
well i would hope he does see it as an
indication of american intent to defeat
him and not just american intent nato
intent to help ukraine defeat him in
ukraine
look at the logic of your question
if we have if we say well gee mr putin
may escalate therefore we have to hold
we have to hold our own responses we're
not only handing ukraine to putin we're
handing the baltic states the same logic
would apply if putin has his designs on
the baltic states and why would he think
that chapter five would save the baltic
states if he sees us cower in responding
to his clearly inhumane war in ukraine
so you're saying that we're almost being
held hostage by our decision not to
enforce a no-fly zone for example
that's correct and look
russia today is a great danger
principally because putin has a serial
provocateur the soviet union was a much
greater threat to the united states yet
we were able to stand up to the soviets
going toe-to-toe without actually
shooting over the berlin crisis in 61
even more over the human missile crisis
in 62 there was no nuclear holocaust
what emboldens putin is western weakness
west western did not the u.s did nothing
after georgia was attacked by russian 08
we did almost nothing after crimea was
attacked we began to do something after
the war and gun box began in 2014 but
not enough
and while we've done a great deal now
and again you have to credit biden with
that we have not done enough
you know if we had sent when ukraine
asked years ago
anti-ship missiles to ukraine
um russia would not have made all that
progress in the south they would not be
bombing odessa if we had sent anti-air
missiles not just stingers but more
powerful missiles to ukraine when they
asked years ago the russian bombardment
over harkev over over kiev would be far
less
our timidity has only emboldened putin's
worst tendencies
he has one great advantage
in uh or two great advantages in this
war
one of course he's a pure nuclear power
of the united states
and he likes to threaten the west with
that
and two he has a kgb operative's nose
for weakness and he smells when he can
intimidate his opponents and he's
smelling intimidation right now and why
do we want to feed that i just don't
know
fascinating listening to you you seem to
be echoing quite a lot of what president
zielinski has said in in recent days
ambassador john herbst uh thank you very
much indeed for your time it's much
appreciated
well more than two and a half million
people have now fled ukraine since the
russian invasion started on the 24th of
february in exodus which is contributing
to a growing humanitarian crisis both
within ukraine as well as in
neighbouring countries one of them
poland has seen more than one and a half
million refugees enter their country
alone
well skies lisa holland reports now from
warsaw
they said this is this is this is what
we organized temporarily
this is just one of the dozens and
dozens of refugee shelters being set up
in warsaw
a welcome camp bed after the bunkers and
the bombs and the days of travel
i love you i love you they long to be
home
but family after family tells of the
trauma of escaping war
yulia struggled to reach kiev train
station with her daughter who has
epilepsy and her son who's autistic
what can i say she says it was so hard
trying to hold my children's hands in
case they fell and carry the luggage
[Applause]
then she reveals
year old nikita is recovering from an
operation after being born with deformed
feet she got here guiding one of her
children who's barely able to walk
others at the shelter need medical help
a young girl is on a drip dehydrated
after the exhaustion of the journey to
poland now made by a million and a half
people
so the problem now because so many
refugees have come to the polish capital
because the authorities are so stretched
they're having to provide more permanent
accommodation or boss people to other
polish cities
this refugee crisis is defined as an
exodus of women and children
across the city there are makeshift
nurseries to entertain the youngsters
and women distraught they've left
husbands brothers and fathers behind in
ukraine
anna's left her husband in kiev she also
has to contend with a mother-in-law in
russia who refuses to accept why she's
fled to poland
she said oh it's just a
little not big not big situation it's
just a little he said mom we had no
house russians destroy our house
across poland thousands of people who
needed no persuasion of the horrors of
this war are taking in refugees
english teacher victor johnson and his
wife offered a home to martyr and her
grandchildren
both of the children's parents are still
in ukraine i didn't speak to marta
before she came here she just turned up
in the car
and so we met them with
high fives and hugs
invited them in
made them feel at home
and
that was the most important thing that
they felt safe secure
we asked roman how he's settling in all
things considered
okay okay nice
just one example of the kindness of
strangers in the midst of war lisa
holland sky news warsaw
you're watching the sky new special
programme on the war in ukraine coming
up in a moment should the west be
tougher in standing up to russian
aggression i'll discuss that with the
ukrainian american international lawyer
[Music]
you